I want to take you now to Kenya were a
number of al-shabaab fighters have been
killed during an attack on a Kenyan
military base which is also used by
American forces the base is located in
lamu County and the site is known as
Camp Simba al-shabaab quickly claimed
responsibility for this attack there's
no word yet on any casualties among
Kenyan or US troops let's get more from
her own Matassa he joins us live from
Nairobi as you say we're still waiting
to hear what any casualties that may
have been incurred by the US or others
in this attack what more are you
learning about well it was an audacious
attack this energy base is manned by the
king ins and the Americans but
al-shabaab still managed to break
through right now we're being told the
attack is over the king and Americans
are now combing the area trying to find
those who were responsible Longwood
Airport it's closed nor flights coming
in or out people working near the area
have been told to go home for their own
security we also know for example that
la mu that particular area lava county
is very volatile it's near Bonnie forest
that's where a lot of ours about
fighters are said to be hiding and over
the years the king and Defense Force
have been going in and out trying to
weed them out and they've been
casualties on both sides on Thursday
there was attack on a passenger bus
traveling in that area they were
ambushed by al-shabaab fighters
suspected al-shabaab fighters they shot
at the bus three people were killed and
people have been told Jaime in that area
to try and be away stay away from
dangerous hotspots like that particular
area al-shabaab has been gaining more
more ground and becoming more more brave
as some people say because they've been
stepping up attacks in Kenya in
neighboring Uganda and most recently in
Somalia last week there was a truck bomb
explosion that killed dozens are people
in the capital Mogadishu al-shabaab says
the reason why they attacking Kenyans in
particular is because the Kenyans are in
Somalia right now the King Air Defense
Forces and they want the Kenyans to
leave Somalia they said if the Kenyans
have no business in that country so
right now on the ground and
it seems tense but calm at the moment
the attack is over but officials the
kingdoms and Americans are still going
through the air trying to find those who
are responsible and April for now still
remains closed just a couple of things
you mentioned that attack last month in
Mogadishu carried out by al-shabaab
we've also seen al-shabaab be attacked
quite heavily by the US and also African
Union forces over the past year or so so
what does this tell us still about the
capacity and the resilience of a group
such as al-shabaab to carry out an
attack inside Kenya like this when you
speak to people they say al-shabaab
seems to be very resilient the way they
fight is they kind of use like guerrilla
tactics for example the the truck bomb
in Somalia they approach the checkpoints
and they exploded a truck that was
carrying explosives and they were
wearing civilian clothing it was a
normal-looking truck so security
officials couldn't really identify them
until it was too late and that is how
they operate they tend to blend in to
the crowd so it's kind of hard to spot
them and it just shows that the number
of texts is stepping up it is harder for
King and official Somali officials other
people in the region to try and fight
them because every time they try to push
them back they keep coming back and
tried to launch these attacks there was
an air strike last week in Somalia the
Americans say they killed a couple of
senior Somali officials they didn't say
who it was but there is an attempt on
the ground from foreign forces the
Kenyans and the Somalis to try and weed
out al-shabaab but is proving very very
difficult and the fact they dare to
attack this military base in Kenya in
the early hours of this morning shows
how audacious they are and it may not be
so easy to weed them out if some analyst
or thing IRA thank you however Matassa
joining us live there from Nairobi
there's much more to discuss about this
attack Matt Brydon is a strategic
advisor at sahaan which is a political
think-tank covering the Horn of Africa
and he joins us now from Nairobi it's
good to have you with us
I really do need to ask you at the
outset here the timing of what we're
seeing taking place but you all know
what the United States involved with at
the mud
with Iran we need to be careful they're
not making a direct link between
al-shabaab and Iran because al-shabaab
is a Sunni group not necessarily linked
to the Shiite Iran but the timing is
interesting do you read anything into
this no I read anything into the timing
of this attack principally because
putting together an attack of this
nature and this audacity would take a
lot of planning a lot of time and it
comes at a moment when al-shabaab has
been especially active along the Kenyan
border making forays into Kenya as we
just heard attacking a civilian bus in
lamu County
less than a week ago so there have been
elements of al-shabaab and principally a
a subunit called the J Simon Islands
army active in lamu County for some time
now so this seems to be part of an
al-shabaab campaign that has been
ongoing for a couple of months now to
project its influence its force both in
the border region inside Somalia and
into Kenya as well now the United States
over the past year has increased its its
attacks on al-shabaab positions inside
Somalia so where is the message being
directed here is this directed to the
United States or also to Kenya of course
who have contributed troops to the
African Union forces in sites a month I
think the message here is actually the
message and if that sounds a bit like a
paradox this attack is very similar to
al-shabaab attack in September on the
join us and Somali military base in
Somalia at Bally dogleg which received a
lot of attention this appears to be
principally an information operation or
a psychological warfare operation where
Shabaab has sent a small number of
Fighters to a major military base they
may or may not have caused the
destruction that that they claim of
aircraft and vehicles at the base
or outside its perimeter but the
propaganda value of having actually
struck across the border hitting an
American a joint Kenyan American
military installation is going to be
much greater than the actual damage that
they've managed to inflict and the fact
that the force was so small indicates
that they didn't intend to overrun the
base they weren't looking for a major
military victory and they issued a
statement so soon after the attack that
it was almost certainly written in
advance pre-prepared
to hit the medians or propaganda point
I'm just like the attack in September
last year so I think what we're looking
at is the evolution of al-shabaab
asymmetric warfare at capacity and its
understanding of a symmetric warfare
operations in a way that is intended to
maximum public impact even if the
military value is limited that
appreciate urinalysis Matt Bryden
joining us there via Skype